as dangerous temperatures hit the west
coast ted was just talking about it
energy companies asking customers to
conserve
this comes after millions of
californians went without power last
year due to a surge in electricity use
during the heat of summer
kate houston spoke to nv energy about
preparations
and ways you can save money on your next
bill an extreme heat wave like this
obviously adds strain to the power grid
throughout the west
excessive heat is forcing southern
nevadans indoors to rely on ac
and appliances that all use energy the
biggest
component of that during the summer is
air conditioning while nv energy
services nearly 1 million customers
locally
they say there's no need to worry about
heat related blackouts or outages in our
area
there's no temperature that's a problem
115 116 117 we've seen it all
this is because they've maintained their
equipment over the past year
we've made upgrades to several of our
power plants that allow them to deliver
more energy to our customers
and we've got solar and battery projects
that have come online in time for this
summer
while they have the capacity to keep
power on they do want the community to
conserve energy
one way to do that is through this
online energy assessment which breaks
down where the energy is going
and how much is being spent we want
customers to be able to stay comfortable
while keeping bills low in addition to
adjusting the thermostat to 78 or higher
and keeping blinds closed
nv energy suggests spacing out the use
of large appliances
using a barbecue outside instead of
cooking in the home is a huge component
running large appliances like
dishwashers and washing machines
wait to run those until late at night or
early in the morning
if you forget to adjust the temperature
in your home envy energy provides free
smart thermostats which will do it for
you
kate houston 8 news now